en 1940 l'allemagne déclenchera le
blitzkrieg une attaque sans précédent
sur une route non préparés et totalement
prise au dépourvu
les divisions blindées d'hitler
surprirent le monde par leur mobilité
un niveau de protection est une
puissance de feu incroyable soumettant
ainsi le continent aux forces de l' axe
les alliés savait qu'ils allaient devoir
lutter contre le temps pour développer
et produire un char capable de vaincre
le troisième reich en 1942 l'angleterre
dévoilait sa nouvelle arme de guerre un
engin dont elle espérait qu'il sauverait
des vies et stopperait l'avancée de la
terreur nazie le churchill
le churchill la grande bretagne contre
attaque en 1916 la première guerre
mondiale entamait sa seconde terrible et
sanglantes années depuis 1914 les
français avaient enduré les plus durs
affrontements contre les allemands au
cours des batailles de la marne et de
verdun les armées françaises étaient à
bord pour les britanniques il était
temps de se rééquiper d' assumer le
lourd fardeau d'un face à face
victorieux et définitif contre l'armée
allemande
le 17 septembre 1916 les britanniques
s'apprêtaient à lancer une arme secrète
qui n'allait pas seulement écrasé les
allemands mais également stopper la
vague mortelle qui décimait les rangs
des alliés l'ère des chars de combat
allait commencer
à l'aube des chars de soutien
d'infanterie
les britanniques inventaire le char et
dès 1917 il en maîtrise l emploi
initialement à son apparition en 1916
l'engin était très primitif ils étaient
disponibles en nombre très restreint et
mécaniquement peu fiable mais c'était un
début et comme tous les nouveaux
systèmes d'armes
cela a pris du temps pour arriver à
maturité mais dès 1917 il était très bon
et en 1918 seuls les britanniques
disposait d'un véritable char par
opposition aux automitrailleuses
surarmés il se furent encore eux qui
intègre r le char au sein d'un ordre de
bataille interarmes de concert avec
l'infanterie et l'artillerie les sapeurs
et de plus en plus la force aérienne
afin de produire une force agressif
combiné sur le champ de bataille
ces dizaines de milliers de fantassins
bien que personne ne soit capable de
dire leur nombre exact doivent leur vie
aux chars de combat ceux-ci brisèrent
littéralement le moral de l'armée
allemande
après de modestes débuts sur la somme et
jusqu'à ambiant où nous avions plus de
400 chars en ligne qui fait une percée
de 13 km dans les défenses allemandes
cette attaque fut décrite par l'ozone
d'offres comme le jour noir de l'armée
allemande à partir de ce jour l'ennemi
n'avait plus aucune chance de gagner
les allemands ne pouvait que faire face
à la défaite est plus tard winston
churchill désignant les équipages de
chars comme les soldats les plus
efficaces de toute l'armée
le char bénéficiait d'une vague de
popularité qui fit le tour de la grande
bretagne
après ces premiers déploiements sur les
champs de bataille de france met tout le
monde dans l'armée ne partageait pas l'
enthousiasme de churchill pour les chars
beaucoup de commandants de cavalerie
pensait que le char n'était qu'un
gouffre financier
après la première guerre mondiale
quelques officiers de l'armée
britanniques pensaient que le char
n'avait été qu'un délire issus du front
de l'ouest durant la grande guerre et
que l'on n'en n'aurai plus jamais besoin
le char n'était pas une arme absolue
malgré tout ce que les journaux et les
marchands d'armes disait mais à la fin
de la guerre il était devenu un sérieux
atout à ajouter aux moyens de combat
déjà existants peut-être pas l'armé
absolue mais une arme tout de même
sacrément utile
les britanniques firent mieux que les
autres nations dans le sens où ils
préservaient leur corps blindé
après la fin de la première guerre
mondiale il le développe r même et lui
donnèrent une place importante au sein
de l'armée un grand débat concernant le
rôle et l'emploi des chars et est-il
simplement une arme d'appui destinée à
soutenir la fonderie auquel cas il
n'avait pas besoin de se déplacer très
rapidement 6 km/heure suffirait
largement car si la vitesse à laquelle
les fantassins pouvait au mieux se
déplacer au contraire les chars
devait-il être capable d'opérer
indépendamment il nécessiterait alors
une vitesse de croisière plus élevé une
capacité de franchissement et une
puissance de feu conséquente
était il seulement une arme défensive ou
bien alors offensive ne servent est il
qu'à la reconnaissance tous ces débats à
propos du rôle des chars combiné aux
restrictions budgétaires amenèrent les
militaires britanniques à une période
d'incertitude durant
l'entre-deux-guerres en 1934
l'un des derniers exercices mécanisée
menée par l'armée de terre fut
simplement pour le dire clairement
organisé par des officiers supérieurs
afin de démontrer que l'infanterie et la
cavalerie traditionnel la cheval était
encore prédominante sur les champs de
bataille de l'époque
à partir de ce jour le combat des
blindés et la guerre mécanisée restèrent
dans l'ombre de la pensée militaire
britannique en revanche le domaine dans
lequel on peut dire que nous et c'est
lyon et l utilisation théorique des
chars malheureusement cette théorie fut
appliquée dès qu'enthousiasmant par
l'armée allemande
des kits l'air 20 au pouvoir et nous
payons cher ces années de négligence
politique
je ne suis pas sûr que les britanniques
en savait très long sur l'activité des
allemands et je ne crois pas qu'il se
sentait très concerné bien qu'ils
eussent dû l'être
les allemands eux savaient exactement où
nous en étions il venait en angleterre
pour de courtes visites formel très bien
organisés ils visitaient telle division
blindée observer son fonctionnement
échanger des idées avec les soldats la
constituent et apprenez beaucoup auprès
d'eux ils repartaient avec ses
enseignements et les appliquer pour la
création de leur propre doctrine
stratégique
les chars produit avant la seconde
guerre mondiale porté les stigmates des
restrictions financières qui avaient
écorné le budget de la défense
britannique en 1935 le constructeur
vickers travaillait avec le gouvernement
à la rédaction des spécifications pour
achard d'infanterie lakers annonçait
qu'il pouvait construire un char pour
moins de quinze mille livres
ce chiffre fut ensuite réduit à moins de
6000 livres mais le char qui naîtrait de
ce cahier des charges à prix réduit
serait-il en mesure de répondre à un
besoin
le mathilde à 1
c'était bien peu de chose c'est des
chenilles un moteur une caisse blindés
une tourelle blindé avec une
mitrailleuse dessus et c'était tout il
ressemblait à un canard et il tirait son
nom du canard d'un dessin animé de
l'époque appelée mathilde à ce qu'on
voulait réellement c'était un char de
combat qui pourrait tout faire mais au
début de la guerre et ensuite pendant un
certain temps ce n'était pas le concept
retenu par les britanniques
nous avons alors produit une série de
chars d'infanterie et le matilda puis
celui avec lequel nous entrâmes en
guerre le à 11 connu sous le nom de
chars d'infanterie mathilde à embarquer
un équipage de deux heures
il était armé d'une mitrailleuse de 3
pouces et son blindage était épais de 60
mm il mesurait 4 mètre 85 de long pour 2
m 28 de large et 1 m 86 de haut pour un
poids de 11 tonnes 16le mathilde à 1
était un véhicule très simple avec un
équipage de deux hommes destinés à
combler un vide
il offrait une certaine protection
il était d'une fiabilité raisonnable le
problème résidait dans sa petite taille
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient emporter
c'était une mitrailleuse qui était en
plus très difficile à utiliser il
pâtissait de tous les problèmes liés à
son coût très réduit
et surtout il ne disposait d'aucune arme
perforantes lui permettant d'affronter
d'autres chars infected ce qui est
intéressant à propos des britanniques
c'est qu'ils étaient les seuls qui
focalisait sur le blindage et c'était
évidemment le principal atout du matilda
le reste et c'est extrêmement médiocre
il pouvait à peine se déplacer au pas il
avait un moteur de voiture ford était
donc sous motorisé avec une suspension
très faible et un armement très léger
c'était littéralement une petite case
mate blindés mobile et n'avait quasiment
aucune puissance il fut assez souvent
utilisé en contre offensive à arras en
1940 ou honnêtement il tint la dragée
haute aux allemands rebelles lui même
failli être tué par l'un d'eux s'étant
fait son adjoint qui fut touché longue
robe elle pensait être attaqué par cinq
brigades
en réalité il était attaqué par trois
régimes
cette contre attaque ne se contenta pas
de bousculer la division de romell elle
et freya toute la division ss engagé en
périphérie le matilda cause à une telle
panique dans les états major allemand
que le raid des panzer division jusqu'à
la côte fut retardé de 24 heures ce
délai est crucial permis d'assurer
l'évacuation de dunkerque
mais ce fut la seule heure de gloire du
mathilda il ne fut jamais réellement bon
mais n'offrit jamais une puissance de
feu suffisante
le mathilde hâte de le charroi des
champs de bataille
le matilda deux marques à un énorme
progrès par rapport aux mathilda il
avait une vraie tour elle avec un canon
de deux livres et un blindage encore
plus épais il était relativement mobile
sa vitesse atteignait près de 20
km/heure donc un peu plus rapide que les
fantassins démarquer et possédait un
rayon d'action satisfaisant le problème
résidait dans son coût de production
beaucoup plus élevé que celui de son
prédécesseur ce qu'il ne pouvait pas
faire s'est étiré les obus explosifs ce
qui le rendait moins efficace en soutien
de l'infanterie que le mathilde un car
tout ce qu'il pouvait faire c'était
attaquer les blindés ennemis ou défendre
l'infanterie
contre des chars adverse en maraude mais
il ne pouvait soutenir l'infanterie par
des tirs d'obus explosifs lors des
attaques
ce qui était pourtant le rôle supposé
des chars d'infanterie à gré mais nés en
2009 et pas beaucoup
un seul régiment de matilda était
disponible lorsque wavel lance à son
offensive contre les italiens en 1940
ces derniers découvrir qu'il ne
disposait d'aucun canon capable de
perforer le blindage du matilda en fait
l'apparence du mathilde a été souvent
suffisante pour dissuader l'infanterie
adverse et l'a poussé à la reddition
c'est ce qui scella le sort de la 10ème
armées italiennes d'abord à bourhani
puis plus tard à hardy et à tobrouk
il n'avait rien à opposer aux mattila
leur propre char est en trés mal conçu
et leurs canons antichars mal adapté
c'est durant cette campagne que le chat
regagna son titre de roi des champs de
bataille
un titre qu'il conserva jusqu'à ce que
l'afrika korps se déploie en afrique du
nord
l'année suivante avec ses redoutables
canons antichars
non s'il connut un énorme succès en
france et lors des premières campagnes
d'afrique résistant aux obus de la
plupart des canons antichars de lax la
seule chose qui pouvait le détruire et
et le canon antiaérien de 88 mm mais il
avait prouvé sa valeur était extrêmement
populaire au sein des troupes
le wallon thain les chiens de terriers
de monti le char d'infanterie ballantine
représentait une avancée par rapport à
ses prédécesseurs il nécessitait un
équipage de trois hommes et il était
armé d'un canon de deux livres ainsi que
de deux mitrailleuses bsa de 7 92 mm son
blindage était effet de 65 mm et il
était mue par un moteur à eux c'est
développant 135 chevaux le propulsant à
une vitesse de 25 km heure avec une
autonomie de 145 kilomètres au départ le
ministère de la guerre n'étaient pas
présents tous dias
à propos du bal en time car il ne
correspondait pas vraiment au rôle de
cruiser tant qu il ne le pensais pas
assez rapide pour ça d'un autre côté il
n'était pas non plus un vrai chars
d'infanterie parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
aussi lourdement blindés que ce que l'on
croyait nécessaire pour ce type de chars
c'était un concept un peu bâtard mais
l'armée avait désespérément besoin de
chars dans les premières phases de la
seconde guerre mondiale il fut donc
décidé de produire ce véhicule une bonne
décision au final car ce fut l'un des
meilleurs chars britannique du début de
la guerre il tirait son nom du fait que
son concept avait été présentée le jour
de la saint valentin
il utilisait des éléments éprouvées
comme la suspension testé sur les chars
moyens à neuf et à 10 ainsi qu'un
excellent moteur qui ne tombait presque
jamais en panne
au moins nous avions un char britannique
qui était mécaniquement fiable mais
c'était toujours un char d'infanterie
dont il était terriblement lents c'est
en réalité c'était un moyen extrêmement
coûteux de porter une mitrailleuse au
cours de la guerre il fut plus
lourdement armés mais avec difficulté
car l'un des problèmes du valentine's
résidait dans sa tourelle très réduite
malgré tout produit une quantité
phénoménale
un tiers des champs britannique produit
pendant la guerre étaient les ballons
times mais il était assez inhabituel de
trouver dans un environnement désertique
un char présentant un tel niveau de
fiabilité
un régiment parcouru la distance d'elles
al amana la tunisie avec les mêmes
véhicules ce qui est un exploit
d'où son surnom le chien de terriers de
monty les inconvénients résidait dans sa
taille relativement petite et sa
tourelle manoeuvrait par deux hommes
alors qu'une tourelle nécessitent
réellement trois soldats autrement
c'était un bon petit véhicule vous
pouviez le camoufler en un morceau de
rocher et devenait presque impossible de
le repérer le churchill
pendant ce temps au royaume uni la
quatrième génération de chars
d'infanterie avait pris forme
lorsque la guerre éclata en 1939 il fut
convenu que même si la guerre des
tranchées appartenait au passé
il y aurait besoin de chars d'infanterie
capable de franchir un terrain dévasté
par l'artillerie et encombrées
d'obstacles variés si le churchill avait
été produit 25 ans plus tôt il aurait
été un ange un brillant car il fut conçu
pour la première guerre mondiale il
avait été imaginé pour le front de
l'ouest tous pensé que ce front de la
grande guerre sur est identique lors de
la seconde guerre mondiale une surface
de chant constellé de trous de but avec
de profondes tranchées des paies
barbelés dans laquelle la vitesse
maximale ne serait pas très importante
mais avec une mobilité permettant aux
chars de franchir des obstacles
malheureusement pour les concepteurs du
churchill la seconde guerre mondiale fut
tout sauf ça ce conflit fut plutôt une
guerre de mouvement et beaucoup des
caractéristiques du churchill supposés
être des qualités allait se révéler
finalement inutile à ce moment précis
nous n'avions plus aucun char en service
dans le pays
il était important dramatiquement
important de produire le plus de sharp
au sigle et voxan se vit notifié la
production et la livraison aux unités de
toute la dotation dans un délai d'un an
cet objectif une attente mais cela ne
laissa pas assez de temps pour les
essais et les évaluations
le churchill était une tentative pour
rectifier les erreurs du passé ils
étaient manoeuvré par un équipage de
cinq hommes emportait un canon de deux
livres une mitrailleuse b e s à 2 7 92
mm et un obusier de 3 pouces son
blindage atteignait 102 mm et son moteur
bedford 12 cylindres développe et 350
chevaux le propulsant à une vitesse
maximale de 25 km heure pour une
autonomie de 145 km
en 1940 nous avions désespérément besoin
d'un char la plupart de ceux que nous
avions furent abandonnées lors de
l'évacuation de dunkerque
c'est ainsi que le churchill fut produit
précipitamment sans avoir été testé au
préalable et inévitablement de gros
problèmes mécaniques ne manquèrent pas
de se manifester
winston churchill lui même n'était pas
très satisfait que son nom fut donné à
une machine qui ne fonctionnait pas très
bien le design du churchill descendait
directement des dessins en losange des
engins de chasse mk1 à mk5 datant de la
grande guerre avec une très large
surface de roulement
c'est pourquoi le churchill paraît
tellement démodé en photo si ressemblant
à un char de la première guerre mondiale
avec ses larges de chenilles lorsque les
équipages commencèrent à s'entraîner sur
le churchill ils furent confrontés à une
multitude de problèmes techniques
il y avait des problèmes de moteurs de
transmissions de chenilles lui même les
pannes par temps de pluie
gardant sat le constructeur n'avait pas
monté les circuits de drainage et la
pluie s'accumulaient sur le plancher
mais vauxhall avait détaché des équipes
d'ingénieurs dans les unités équipées de
churchill
q résolurent ces problèmes très
rapidement grâce à une série de
modifications au final leurs manuels
disait nous savons que ce véhicule n'est
pas parfait un des puissants suivait
toute une liste de fautes qui furent
corrigé très rapidement
ainsi à la fin 1941 début 1942 nous
disposions d'un char opérationnel acte
les équipages appréciait le churchill
par exemple il s'enflammait beaucoup
moins facilement que le sherman
lorsqu'ils étaient touchés l'un des plus
gros défaut du sherman était de prendre
feu dès qu'il était touché
vous pouviez vous extraire du churchill
beaucoup plus facilement que de
n'importe quel autre char car il avait
deux trappes latéral relativement facile
à atteindre
il était également assez spacieux à
l'intérieur et il était confortable
churchill avait une apparence inhabituel
car ces chenilles est légal est autour
desquels est donné sans rouler dépassé
de l'avant du char ce qui lui faisait
comme de grosses cornes et c'est dans
ces termes qu'on le surnommait beaucoup
d'ingénieurs trouvé cela inacceptable
car cela restreignait la visibilité du
pilote qui se trouvait très reculées
dans la caisse quoi qu'il en soit les
chars étaient si bruyant et la vision du
pilote était si restreinte que la
restreindre un peu plus ne faisait guère
de différence sur le champ de bataille
et cela n'était pas trop mal à
l'intérieur du char lorsqu'on regardait
vers l'avant depuis la caisse on voyait
le poste de pilotage sur la droite avec
les commandes habituelles sauf qu'à la
place des deux leviers de direction dont
la plupart des chars et est équipé vous
trouviez une sorte de guidon autrement
l'emplacement du mitrailleur de caisse
se trouvait sur la gauche
et l'on peut voir son poste de tir avec
la mitrailleuse b e s a monté sur rotule
est ici la visée du canon à l'intérieur
de la tourelle vous voyez ici le poste
du chef de char sur l'avant gauche avec
le siège du tireur et les commandes de
tirs juste devant lui
vous pouvez également constaté que le
churchill était un véritable capharnaüm
avant l'avènement des autoroutes
la plupart des mouvements de blindés à
grande échelle encombraient les voies de
communication à cause de cela il fut
décidé qu'une tourelle à deux hommes
serait la plus adaptée car il n'abritait
que le tireur et le chef de char cela
signifiait que ce dernier devait non
seulement dirigé le pilote en lui disant
ou à l'est mais aussi le tireur s'il
pouvait repérer l'ennemi ordonné des
tirs tout en gérant les communications
radio avec les autres chars de son unité
quant au chef de peloton et d'escadrons
il était en plus de tout cela en contact
avec le commandement
ce qui était complètement inappropriée
sur un champ de bataille moderne
le chef de peloton avait alors une telle
charge de travail
il devait finalement choisir entre
rester en contact avec les autres chars
de son unité ou faire feu sur l'ennemi
assez rapidement on se rendit compte
qu'une tourelle à trois hommes était un
minimum et que de nombreuses
modifications sur le plan d'étude des
chars allait être nécessaire pour
pouvoir y adapter de nouvelles tours
elle plus tard au cours de la guerre
désastre à dieppe le churchill fut
déployé la première fois à dieppe en
france le 19 août 1942 un raid fut
lancée pour tester les défenses d'une
zone littorale ennemis lourdement
fortifiée les tragiques leçons apprises
serait appliquée plus tard lorsque les
alliés revint sur le continent européen
et si on a souvent cru que le churchill
essuyé un cuisant échec à dieppe et nous
l'avons tous dit oui les tshirts ils
débarquèrent sur la plage mais n'importe
quel char qui aurait débarqué sur la
plage de dieppe aurais tu sais problème
et le problème c'est que c'était une
plage de galets les canadiens assurèrent
le gros du travail et c'est l'un de
leurs régiments de churchill le cal
guérir agent qui débarqua depuis les
navires c'est là que les choses allaient
mal tourné les chenilles dassier n'avait
simplement aucune accroche sur les
galets de tout petits cailloux qui
glissait dans tous les sens et plus les
chenilles patinait plus les chars
s'enfonçait il y avait ensuite une digue
les chars devait donc franchir la plage
et escalader la digue
une procédure avait été mise en place
pour cela les sapeurs devait débarquer
et placer des rampes de bois pour que
les chars puisse passer par dessus la
digue et ainsi entrer dans la ville mais
les sapeurs se perdirent ou leur barque
pour couler il n'atteignait jamais la
plage et ceux qui parvint ne purent
jamais placer les rampes laissant les
chars bloqué par la digue
mais cela serait arrivé avec n'importe
quel char de cette époque personne
n'aurait été capable de sortir de cette
plage ce n'est pas quelque chose
imputable au churchill c'est réellement
l'opération qui fut compromise les
performances du churchill n'ont été ni
pire ni meilleur que ce qu'on pouvait en
attendre donc
diack ne représente en aucun cas un test
crédible des véritables capacités de ce
char
nous n'avons pu embarquer ni réembarquer
aucun de ces chars qui tombèrent tous
aux mains de l'ennemi
quand les allemands va réexaminer le
churchill ils crurent un engin d'une
autre guerre ils allèrent jusqu'à penser
qu'ils étaient obsolètes que c'était des
engins des classes et dont nous voulions
nous débarrasser il ne voyait pas
comment le churchill pouvait entrer dans
un schéma de combat de blindés il ne le
pouvait d'ailleurs pas il se dire qu'il
était inopportun pour nous de vouloir
développer notre propre arme blindés car
le churchill était clairement une
bizarrerie mécanique inutile
victoire en afrique du nord
après la défaite cuisante de dieppe la
carrière du churchill semblait
compromise
avant même d'avoir débuté plutôt que de
remplacer le churchill en service il fut
décidé d'envoyer un contingent dans le
désert d'afrique du nord
c'est là que le churchill fut obligé de
relever le défi sous peine d'être mis à
la casse
je
le churchill eu son baptême du feu en
afrique du nord c'est en tunisie plus
que dans les plaines de limites il pu
réellement s'exprimer
un nombre restreint de churchill fut
déployée dans le désert pour constituer
une unité d'évaluation baptisé king
force sa première opération fut l
allemagne lors de laquelle il se
comporte a remarquablement bien
c'était très important pour le churchill
à ce stade car tout le projet était
menacée d'annulation le churchill fut
incroyablement utile à la surprise
générale car il était réellement
obsolète et tout à coup nous découvrions
un char qui franchissent à lépante avec
une aisance incroyable très utile en
tunisie soit j'ai eu vent d'une anecdote
selon laquelle un chef d'escadron avait
placé ses chars sur une pente dont
personne n'aurait jamais pensé qu'elle
était franchissable
ils les guida à pied ce qui est assez
ébouriffante
bien entendu cela n'arrivait pas
systématiquement parfois sur une pente
un char pouvez glisser basculer et une
fois que cela commençait cela ne
s'arrêtait plus j'ai le souvenir d'un
incident horrible au cours duquel un
churchill se retourna sur le flanc d'une
colline très raide et fit six tonneaux
avant d'arriver en bas latourelle
arraché du châssis et tous les membres
d'équipages tués c'est le genre de
risques que les tankistes qui servait
sur churchill prenait car il avait
énormément confiance dans leur véhicule
il savait que neuf fois sur dix ils ne
les laisserai pas tomber
ils furent tous durement touchée par des
canons antichars de tous calibres et des
tirs d'artillerie et malgré tout ils
parvinrent à survivre remarquablement
bien
globalement le baptême du feu du
churchill dans le désert occidental fut
donc très encourageant
il joua un rôle très important dans le
sens où comme les défenses de lax était
positionné autour de la vallée de match
jourda la voie d'accès vers tunis le
churchill dû franchir ces collines et y
affronter l'ennemi
une fois la principale auteure conquise
l'issue était cousu de fil blanc et vous
pouviez mesurer combien de temps elle
est passée avant la conquête de la
colline suivante quasiment prédire à
l'avance le moment où lac se rendrait
donc oui le churchill fut la clé qui
permit d'ouvrir la porte et après cela
ce n'était plus qu'une opération de
nettoyage
au delà de la capacité du churchill a
grimpé les collines mise à mal par son
centre de gravité subsistait le vieux
problème de la coopération entre
l'infanterie et les blindés selon les
villes dillmann ancien officier de la 7e
division blindée il existait une
difficulté d'entente entre les
fantassins et les tentes east nous
étions sous un déluge de feu
mais quand vous êtes dans un char même
inconfortable car c'était des tirs
d'artillerie pas des obus antichar
ça n'était pas très inquiétant nous
étions vraiment désolé pour les
fantassins qui étaient autour de nous
pendant que nous essuyons ses tirs
d'artillerie sur pied très étrange c'est
que ces fantassins se disait toujours oh
mon dieu je ne voudrais pas être dans
ces boîtes de conserve pour tout l'or du
monde tandis que nous avions l'habitude
de dire or les pauvres types odeurs au
moins nous nous sommes relativement
protégé les britanniques printemps
horriblement long à mettre en place une
coopération efficace entre infanterie et
blinder les tankistes ne faisait pas
réellement confiance aux fantassins et
réciproquement
il ne s'entraînait pas assez ensemble
ils ne coordonnait jamais vraiment leur
action et ce même plus tard dans le
déroulement de la guerre il y avait
d'autres raisons à cela et notamment les
communications
il était très difficile pour un
fantassin de parler un chef de char
toutes les radios n'étaient pas
compatibles entre elles
lorsqu un lance-roquettes anti-char
portable faisait feu c'était un gros
souci pour les chats l'avancée
technologique qui rendit cela possible
depuis l'apparition des obus à charge
creuse qui par leur est chauffé à blanc
déclenché l enfer à l'intérieur du char
causant le chaos et la panique
comme on peut l'imaginer un fantassin
ennemis portant un puncheur faust ou un
bazooka pouvait se trouver quasiment
main pour tous 6e fantassins était assez
courageux pour rester à couvert jusqu'à
ce que le char se trouve à portée de tir
ces armes anti-char sur révélèrent
dévastatrice
j'avais trouvé une bonne position dans
une ornière où les camions étaient
passés et les ornières était si profonde
que je pu me glisser je tirais cinq
projectiles sur un char ils étaient
énormes et j'étais droit face à son
canon comme je tirais une dernière
requête il tira un coup qui arriva sur
ma gauche et je fus touché sur tout le
flanc gauche de ma tête mon épaule il
fallut reconsidérer les tactiques
d'emploi des chars d'infanterie c'est à
partir de ce moment là les chars les
monnaies les attaques à découvert comme
c'était le cas auparavant
dans les zones cloisonnés comme les
vignobles bocage sous bois zones
urbaines l'infanterie passerait de vents
soutenus par les chars progressant juste
derrière les variantes du churchill
alors que la guerre se poursuivaient et
que le bilan s'alourdissait il devint
dramatiquement clair que les sapeurs
avaient grand besoin de véhicules
spécialisés pour les aider dans leurs
dangereux travail ce besoin urgent donna
naissance au churchill avait heureux
l'une des leçons apprises lors du raid
de dieppe était de connaître à l'avancé
les défenses ennemies pour savoir quels
types d'obstacles nous aurions à
surmonter pour franchir ce que hitler
appelait son mur de l'atlantique le
churchill été grâce à sa taille une base
très adapté à la conversion vers une
large gamme d'engins de génie être
sapeur de combat est un travail
extrêmement dangereux essayé de retirer
ou démolir des obstacles des ponts des
mines est sous le feu ennemi
et comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
incroyablement coûteux en vies humaines
quelques méthodes ont vu le jour pour
éviter cela le churchill trouva qu'il
était une plateforme idéale avec son
excellente mobilité et son épais
blindage il avait un profil assez
ramassé ce qui permettait d'installer
des équipements supplémentaires sans
trop grossir sa silhouette génère
développèrent une tourelle spéciales
pour y monter un mortier de 290 mm qui
tirait une charge
appelez-la poubelles volantes et sept
poubelles volantes était capable
d'ouvrir littéralement un bunker en
béton watts
l'autre appareil utilisé sur le
churchill avait et recommande le no mais
était un pont à poutres elle que l'on
pouvait poser contre une digue qui il
avait de gros fagots aujourd'hui
constitué de tuyaux mais à l'époque des
deux guerres mondiales il était fait de
fagots de bois
il fallait donc être très prudent avec
il était extrêmement lourd à tel point
qu'il nécessitait un char avec une
solide suspension pour les transporter
on pouvait les verser dans n'importe
quelle tranche est pour ensuite la
franchise un léger problème apparu avec
le churchill la première fois qu'il s'en
servir liée au fait qu'il avait placé le
fagot à l'arrière de l'engin
le pot d'échappement placé lui aussi à
l'arrière mils feu aux fagots de bois ce
qui fut assez effrayant pour l'équipage
il le placèrent par la suite à l'avant
bien que cela empêche a dû utiliser
l'armement principal nous étions
satisfaits des churchill car il
nettoyait les champs de mines avec leur
fléau
quand il arrivait nous étions vraiment
très heureux leur rôle était d'éviter
des morts supplémentaires dans ce qui
était déjà un terrible gâchis humain et
ils en firent la preuve avec un énorme
succès en normandie l'une des variantes
les plus intimidantes et dévastatrice du
churchill était le churchill crocodiles
armé d'un lance flammes il fut déployé
en normandie après le débarquement de
croco d'agde était l'une de ses
variantes habituellement un dérivé du
churchill parfois un cromwell mais plus
rarement
c'était en fait un gros lance flammes
mobile il tractait derrière lui une
grande remorque de napalm et ils avaient
sur l'avant un canon qui crachait les
flammes le canon crachait son jet de
flammes jusqu'à 90 mer ce feu restait
collé à tout ce qu'il touchait c'était
une arme terrible assez souvent il
travaillait en coordination avec le av n
av
celui-ci tiré ces obus de mortier ouvrez
un blockhaus et si les occupants ne
sortait pas rapidement le croco d'agde
s'approchait et enflammé l'intérieur le
napalm enflammé coulé à l'intérieur et
forcer les occupants à sortir très utile
pour nettoyer les bunkers où les réseaux
de tranchées
on peut dire que c'était quand même un
horrible moyen de tuer
souvent la simple apparition du croco
d'agde était suffisante pour que
l'ennemi se rendent à linverse si un
équipage de croco d'agde et est fait
prisonnier il ne fallait pas s'attendre
à beaucoup de pitié à son endroit
je ne dirais pas qu'ils aimaient leur
boulot un ancien dentiste sur croco
d'eyl m'a confié un jour qu'il le
trouvait inhumain vous pouvez imaginer
le résultat du passage d'un crocodile
une fois qu'on avait vu cela on ne
pouvait plus l'oublier
c'était vraiment atroce la guerre
elle-même est atroce mais c'est le
résultat qui compte
c'est pour cela que vous voulez acheter
c'était une arme particulièrement
horribles les équipages de churchill
croco d'agde pouvait s'attendre à très
peu de ménagement de la part des
allemands cas de capture
malgré tout il faut dire qu en de
nombreuses occasions la simple présence
d'un char lance flammes étaient
suffisantes pour forcer les allemands
qui en d'autres circonstances aurait
résisté à se rendre immédiatement cette
arme tout aussi une humaine qu'elle fut
par ailleurs sauver d'autres vies
donc ça n'était peut-être pas une arme
aussi inhumaine que l'on pouvait
l'imaginer
duel en normandie
le 6 juin 1944 les alliés lancèrent d'un
débarquement amphibie sur les plages de
normandie leur plan était d'amener la
majorité des blindés allemands dans les
secteurs britannique et canadien pour
permettre aux américains de sortir de la
plage pour réaliser cela
les régiments de churchill appuyèrent un
grand nombre de raids d'infanterie sur
les villages tenus par l'ennemi mais les
allemands avaient prévu de résister
farouchement
hitler avait formellement interdit à ses
troupes de lâcher un pouce de terrain et
les allemands lancèrent de furieuses
contre attaque avec leur tigre panthère
et les panzers grenadiers les soldats
alliés étaient conscients de leur
désavantage
non seulement ils s'attendaient à
combattre sur un terrain sur lequel leur
char pouvait difficilement évolué mais
il aurait en plus affronter un ennemi
retranché et armés de chats plus
puissant et d'armes antichars
la situation était mal engagement
en combat le churchill ne pouvait
affronter le panthères ni le tigre ni
même le panzer 4 il ne jouait tout
simplement pas dans la même catégorie
et si vous vous retrouviez face à 1.941
tigre ou un panthères vous évitiez la
confrontation autant que possible vous
utilisiez le churchill et ses variantes
dont nous avons parlé précédemment
les chars lance flammes et autres où
vous les utilisiez en terrain accidenté
car il était à l'aise mais vous ne les
engagent et pas contre des tigres la
principale raison pour laquelle le
churchill resta en service sur le front
tout au long de la guerre était son
épais blindage frontale sa survie sur le
champ de bataille
il était le seul char alliés y compris
les chars américains qui pouvait ne
serait ce qu'envisager de résister à un
panthère ou un tigre en combat il
n'aurait jamais pu les détruire mais ils
pouvaient au moins essayer de tenir le
terrain qu'il venait de prendre en
attendant d'autres moyens d'appuyer en
route pour l'aider combat de chars face
à face le churchill disposait d'un
blindage bien plus épais qu'aucun autre
véhicule alliés mais apporter combat il
restait très vulnérable à face aux obus
allemands de 75 mm et 88 mm une histoire
tristement célèbre est celle d'un
peloton de churchill des prix en
l'espace de deux ou trois minutes par
trois ou quatre panthères allemand armé
de canons de 88 mm sous bien des aspects
ils avaient une meilleure durée de vie
que beaucoup d'autres charges alliés
mais il pâtit c'est toujours de son
canon de 75 mm qui pouvait au mieux
servir contre des chars allemands à
déporter très réduite
mais arrivé si près et est difficile
sous beaucoup d'aspects le churchill
était désavantagé car ils ne pouvaient
pas se déplacer à une vitesse élevée
comme le crom - elle est peut-être le
sherman d'où les chars allemands même le
panthères était très silencieux
vous ne les entendrez pas jusqu'à ce que
quelqu'un dise
et il y en a un qui arrive au coin il
était très silencieux alors que nous
charment année churchill êtes un tel
boucan qu'on pouvait les entendre
arriver à un kilomètre à la ronde
jane l'esprit en général il était
difficile pour les churchill quel qu'en
fût le nombre d'affronter un groupe de
tigres assez souvent je pense à
plusieurs exemples en italie
l'artillerie moyenne fut la seule
solution pour dégager les churchill même
lorsque le canon de six livres fut monté
comme ce fut le cas plus tard avec
quelques churchill la capacité de
pénétration de blindage contre le tigre
et deux panthères n'était pas encore
suffisant
au combat les tshirts il n'avait jamais
davantage et les équipages en avaient
vraiment assez il aurait voulu pouvoir
se battre d'égal à égal
le prince noir
dans une tentative de mettre le
churchill au niveau du panthère ou du
tigre il fut décidé de construire un
super churchill le nouveau churchill
merveilleusement baptisée prince noir
allait recevoir une nouvelle tour elle
avec un canon de 17 livres qui était un
excellent canons antichars
pour y arriver il fallu élargir la
caisse effectué de nombreuses autres
modifications à l'intérieur du char un
certain nombre de prototypes furent
construits mais malheureusement le
prince noir n'entra en production que
trop tard pour participer à la seconde
guerre mondiale il fut le chant du cygne
du concept de chars d'infanterie
malheureusement il arrive à bien
évidemment trop tard pour avoir un
quelconque impact sur l'issue de la
guerre mais il fut utilisé lors de la
guerre de corée au cours de laquelle sa
capacité à grimper les collines combinée
à son excellent canon dépassé tout ce
que les chinois ou les nord-coréens
pouvait produire bien que le prince noir
arriva après la capitulation des forces
de l' axe le churchill avait une guerre
de plus amené en novembre 1951 un
escadron de croco d'agde débarqua en
corée il faisait partie de la 29e
brigade d'infanterie britannique
à ce stade la guerre basculer rapidement
du nord au sud et inversement
l'idée d'enflammer des positions
fortifiées ne s'appliquait pas dans ces
circonstances particulières et
l'escadron à l'exception d'un cas
abandonna ses remorques et combattit
comme avec des chars conventionnelle
dotés de canons ils aidèrent à dégager
un bataillon d'infanterie pris au piège
évacuant la plupart de ces compagnies il
manoeuvre air également avec les
américains qui ne furent pas avares de
louanges
ils combattirent magnifiquement sur les
collines coréenne
excepté en hiver où les chenilles
d'acier n'accrochait pas sur la toundra
à moitié gelé
depuis ses débuts sur les champs de
bataille ensanglanté de la grande guerre
aux pentes arides de la corée du nord
le char de soutien d'infanterie joue un
rôle crucial dans ces conflits qui ont
changé la face du monde
après des décennies de restrictions
budgétaires d'indécision et une série de
chars décevant les espoirs de
l'angleterre et de son armée reposer sur
le churchill
malgré ces débuts désastreux sur les
plages de dieppe sa légendaire capacité
de franchissement le sauva de la casse
il contribuera également à bouter les
forces de l' axe hors d'afrique du nord
le churchill fut un pionnier sur le
champ de bataille et mérite sa place
parmi l'un des meilleurs chars que la
grande bretagne ait jamais produit
le churchill bien que l'en est
apparemment démodé était un vieux
survivants des champs de bataille et
pour cette raison le fait qu'il puisse
encaisser temps de mauvais traitements
sur la ligne de front le place parmi les
meilleurs chars britannique de toute la
guerre le churchill en une phrase fut
incroyablement résistants ils avaient
une excellente mobilité tout terrain
c'était vraiment un superbe chars avec
un tout petit canon le churchill fut
conçu et prévu pour une guerre qui n'eut
jamais lieu
il avait toutes sortes de défaut à ses
débuts mais sa capacité à escalader les
pentes lui donna un sursis et son
aptitude à être déclinée en d'autres
variantes lui permis d'allonger sa durée
de vie bien au delà de ce qu'elle aurait
dû être